we are ended with Alice Lee after a
tremendous performance in a game one
Alice every time I see you it feels like
you're more and more confident your game
gains more confidence do you feel that
way as well and I've seen you play in
the Pro chess league as well you've been
carrying uh the Saint Louis archbishops
how do you feel about that and this
tournament yeah I think like the past
few tournaments including like the
protest League I had like a lot of
opportunity to play against really
strong players
um this tournament is no exception so I
feel as though like I can
um I can realistically speak and have
chances against anybody uh and in this
opening uh this game I guess
um I think it was like a pretty smooth
game I got a good position of the
opening and then I felt like I had like
a very pleasant and came to play and she
had like lower time so yeah I think this
game definitely went well but I still
have another game tomorrow how did you
come up with this idea of starting off
with this aggressive F3 against the name
Zo
um so I
I felt like I want to have like a win
um at least here I have better chances
with the white pieces
and uh and it's the first game so you
want to put pressure on her yeah so
um this move is like something that I've
never played before it's sort of like
gets out of her preparation and
um yeah I like I overall just thought
that like this was a good line to play
especially to play for a win
um so she probably wouldn't be reviewing
this before the game and uh I would be
able to get a position where I just
reviewed it so it's more comfortable for
me to like play I probably will have
more time out of the opening
um and yeah I think that strategy worked
for this game
and did you feel that you're achieving
your goals based on her time Spencer in
the position it didn't feel like she's
very comfortable uh with this position
yeah
um so actually I didn't know this line
too well I knew up to like uh move 12
and then I didn't know what to play
after year yeah so
I think uh this is like a pleasant
position
um and like obviously I had like a a bit
more time than her
uh 10 minutes more and I think in this
position uh I thought like this would be
pretty Pleasant I didn't know exactly
but I thought like I probably will be
able to like trade into an end game and
I'll probably play like E4 and my Bishop
on uh the dark sir Bishop is really good
um so I thought I had pretty good
winning chances here and that's exactly
what happened you entered this Superior
end game
just slightly but definitely you have
some pressure and you're playing for two
results
how did you assess it and what were your
strategic AIMS in this end game what
were you playing for uh so here I guess
I have like 30 minutes yes uh 11. so
um I thought like uh this position I
didn't I didn't know whether it was like
a win or a draw uh I thought like if I
saw that the work Indian would
definitely be like really unpleasant for
her to play especially with much lower
time and I felt like I had extremely
good practical mini chances so I'm not
sure if this was like I had any
um other better moves here but I thought
objectively this was uh practically
speaking this is like um this should be
like very hard for her to play and he
made that transition and Yasser was in
fact very happy with this transition he
was giving you more than 75 chances at
this point to win this game did you feel
the same yeah I thought like
um if I'm able to sort of defend
consolidate the king side still remain
upon up then I can probably like
activate mykin more toward the center
um possibly create like G3 F4 passed
upon
um which I think I sort of uh did in the
game and then like maybe bring my
kingdom more
um and yeah I think the a Pawn on the
side is to my advantage even though my
work is stuck defending it because yeah
here eventually I was able to win it
after her work got sidetracked and after
this I think I was just winning very
nice Alice congratulations on an
explosive start in this tournament guys
any questions absolutely first of all
our congratulations to you uh Alice for
a wonderful start to your campaign this
year last year you were a finalist
um but you're coming into this
tournament with one year's experience
and it seems to ourselves that this one
year has been very very good to you
you're your your career is uh you you've
been doing great why
um I think I spent like a lot of time on
chess especially like
um I've been trying to like Branch out
in my play style uh like go for these
more attacking openings
um and I think uh the past year has been
pretty good uh I think mostly I just
gained a lot more experience especially
from like playing in these tournaments I
played in this last year and I think
that gave me like
um a lot of like experience playing
against drum players and I've been uh
playing and drawn tournaments like
almost every month so I think overall my
uh form is pretty good I just like
played in a tournament before this
um and yeah so I think like overall uh
the past year I definitely gained more
experience and that has definitely
helped me improve yeah and uh once again
congratulations on on winning your first
game and you mentioned that you were
playing a lot of Chess and I'm sure all
parents out there would be really dying
to know
um how do you combine chess with the
schoolwork
um so I'm actually a part-time student
I'm in eighth grade so uh there isn't
too much schoolwork
um
I have like one math class at the
University which is taking like a lot of
time but other than that I think uh
since I'm still in middle school next
year would probably be like more uh like
tough for me to manage with schoolwork
but I'll still keep trying to like play
chess I can probably like I usually talk
to my teachers before I go to a
tournament so they can give me their
before time and I try to do it uh before
or sometimes
um like during our after tournaments and
yeah I think overall like the balance
for schoolwork and chess hasn't been too
difficult for me although I have missed
like a lot of school you said the word
universe
exactly Alice you alerted us what did
you mean by that what did you what about
University what type of University are
you authentic
um they're the math program at the U of
M called MTM so it's like
um pretty Advanced and
um it like teaches people from like six
to 12th grade
um high school and college math So
currently I'm in my first year of
calcuon and
um
it's like
um it's been a bit difficult to keep up
but I think overall since my grades are
okay
um I usually try to they only have like
one class a week so I only have to like
uh if I have like a tournament I can
probably like do stuff beforehand
um but yeah overall that's like the only
difficult class for me
um and the rest is okay
well Alice congratulations go to
somewhere calculon homework and I
stopped at college algebra guys I mean I
stopped that college algebra you
probably passed that congratulations
we'll see you tomorrow thank you wow